we can bring you an update now from
Lancashire police they have just
released a new image of a potential
witness in The Disappearance of Nicola
bully they are looking for this woman
pictured here walking her dog in the
same area that Nicola bully went missing
they say that the search is continuing
today for Nicola who were missing last
Friday
um they would now like to speak to the
woman pictured in this CCTV image who
the police believe was in the area at
the time Nicola was last seen and who
may have information that could help
them Lancashire police say we would
stress that this woman is sought as a
witness and nothing more as you can see
from the picture there she is wearing a
red and white coat with a fur hood
light-colored trousers and a light
Bobble hat she was walking a small white
dog this image was captured on CCTV at
around 8 48 a.m on allotment Lane which
is close to where Nicola was last seen
and was also seen near to the gate at
the end of allotment Lane Lancashire
police say if you believe this is you or
you recognize the woman please get in
touch they have also confirmed a
timeline from the morning Nicola was
last seen
um it goes in this order 8 43 a.m Nicola
bully was walking along the path by the
river wire having dropped her children
off at school at approximately 8 50 a.m
a dog walker somebody who knows Nicola
saw her walking around the lower field
with her dog their two dogs interacted
briefly before the witness left the
field via the river path
8 53 a.m Nicholas sent an email to her
boss at 901 am she logged on to a team's
call
at approximately ten past nine a witness
somebody again who knows Nicola saw her
on the upper field walking her dog
Willow work is ongoing today to
establish exactly what time this was but
as the police say it's around
approximately ten past nine
at 9 30 the team's call ended but Nicola
stayed logged on at approximately 9 35
a.m Nicholas mobile phone and Willow the
Dog were found at a bench by the river
by another dog walker so that is the
latest from the police a rough timeline
of the last movements of Nicola bully
before her disappearance again they have
released this new CCTV image of a dog
walker in the area they are stressing
that if this is you or you recognize
this woman please get in touch this
woman is being sought as a witness and
nothing more that could have some
important information for the police in
the continuing investigation Into The
Disappearance of Nicola bully